I think it's definitely possible to be a
libertarian and a Mormon i'm dustin
peterson i'm on the board of latter-day
saints for ron paul i go to a school of
BYU Idaho in the history of the
latter-day saints there's always been a
strong constitutionalist movement the
founder of the LDS church Joseph Smith
believe that the Constitution was a
inspired document and every leader since
then has held relatively the same view
when Ron Paul goes up into the Bates and
talks about the Constitution I think
that's the one thing that connects me to
Ron Paul the most and other latter-day
sites another thing is war there's a
strong tradition of being anti war
within the church one of our profits
Ezra Taft Benson was a big proponent of
staying out of it and tangling alliances
staying out of the United Nations
staying out of NATO if we actually look
at our history many leaders of our
church were not exactly all in favor of
these wars so that's another position
that I like to connect I think most
Mormons wasn't voting for Mitt Romney
just because he is Mormon but I know
that about half the students that are
politically active at byu-idaho are Ron
Paul supporters and the other half or
Mitt Romney so I think there's a really
a battle right now going on in the
campuses of the future of the Republican
Party between even within the Mormon
schools there's Ron Paul supporters that
are you know quite motivated to support
Ron Paul I think it's definitely
possible to be a libertarian and a
Mormon within our faith there's a
concept called agency and that's close
to liberty and so I think an arched in
our faith were taught to make choices
and decide based on our agency you know
whether to drink whether to smoke and
we're told not to but we saw that agency
so I think that's something else we can
apply in government as well in the
history of the Mormon Church the
government didn't protect the Mormons
religious faith really the religious
rights I think there's a lot of distrust
among Mormons with government and their
ability to protect us the church it
encourages people to vote you know the
pulpit on Sunday it's you're told to go
out and vote and support the candidate
of your choice so I think that's why
there's such a strong voting bloc is
because we're encouraged to vote in
church I think we're going to do strong
in Idaho it's one of those states that
has a strong woman voting population and
I think those Mormons are going to turn
out for Ron Paul